[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
ginga's Khan founder of the Mongol
Empire who lived between 1162 and 12 27
ad is believed to be one of the most
prolific fathers in history his Mongol
domain became the world's largest
contiguous Empire eventually
encompassing all of modern-day China
Korea the Caucasus Central Asia a
substantial portion of Eastern Europe
and Southeast Asia in addition to being
a brutal and brilliant military leader
he had a lot of wives and concubines as
he swept across Asia conquering cities
and villages
ginga's Kahn would assume many of the
wives of leaders he had conquered by his
death at age 65 he may have had up to
three thousand wives and concubines and
fathered more than a thousand children
in fact ginga's Kahn was so fruitful
that the genetic analysis has shown one
in 200 men in the world today is
believed to be a direct descendent of
the Mongol ruler sharing the same Y
chromosome did you know the Bible says
being a real father requires more than
just spawning offspring stay with his
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you've not tuned in
before then we're glad you're tuning in
now this is a live international
interactive Bible study and we have
lines open I mean a lot of people are at
home now that might not normally be
because of what's been happening with
the pandemic in recent months and we
invite you to join us in this Bible
study you can call lines open eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven we're not only on the phone via
phone call you can watch what's
happening at Facebook and that's the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page or the
amazing facts Facebook page you just
type in amazing facts Facebook our Doug
magic that's where you can see what's
going on here in the studio and join us
or call in again with your questions
it's 800 god says eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven and I am Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and happy Father's Day
to you Pastor Doug like a lot of fathers
out there that are tuning in and this is
of course Father's Day when we are
recording this program but before we get
to our Bible questions and we talked a
little bit about our free offer for
today let's just bow our heads for a
word of Prayer dear father we thank you
that you are our Father we thank you for
the many blessings that you've bestowed
upon us we thank you for your word and
for the opportunity for us to study and
understand who you are and also come to
a clear understanding of your will for
our lives so we ask your blessing upon
our program be with those who are
listening for we ask this in Jesus name
Amen
amen well pastor doc you mentioned of a
spoke of a very prolific father that had
I guess there's no real number to attach
to how many descendants he had directly
from him sons and daughters and
grandchildren I was thinking of a Bible
character who also had close to well at
least a thousand we'd think somebody in
that neighborhood for wife cos Solomon
had multiple wives but here we're
talking about a monarch we had what
three thousand wives or concubines yeah
that's the estimate you can imagine the
number of kids he would
yeah it's and it's only through the
genetics they found this one Y
chromosome that they traced back to his
time in his area and there is all
research study that was done on this a
few years ago and they said wow he
spawns a lot of offspring and I said
it's probably good that he did because
he was guilty of genocide about as much
as any ancient ruler you know he just
wiped out some entire countries and but
yeah he tried to repopulate them himself
evidently but there's more to being a
father than just reproducing you know
God told us be fruitful and multiply but
he doesn't want fathers or mothers to
leave it at that point the Bible tells
us that Christian parenting involves
modeling a christ-like life to your
children and fathers the Bible says in
Psalm 103 13 as a father has compassion
on his children so the Lord has
compassion on those that fear Him
fathers should love their children the
Bible says in Deuteronomy 131 therefore
you saw how the Lord God carried you as
a father carries his son all the way you
went until you reach this place he
protects his children proverbs 4 1 it
says here my children the instruction of
a father give attention to no
understanding for I give you good
doctrine a father teaches his children
in Matthew 7 11 which of you if he has a
son and asks for bread won't give him a
stone or if he asks for a fish will he
give him a snake if you then though your
evil know how to give good gifts to your
children how much more will your Father
in Heaven give good gifts to those who
ask him a good father provides for his
children and then it tells us in Hebrews
that a loving father will also Chasen
Hebrews 12 verse 6 for whom the Lord
loves he chastens and scourges every son
whom he receives if you endure
chastening then God deals with you as
sons for what son is there whom a father
does not chasing so the Lord is telling
us here that a father loves he
disciplines he provides he teachers
he protects and maybe this is why Jesus
told us that when we pray he said pray
in this manner our Father you know he
told her he built one of the most loving
relationships the human relationship we
can understand and because the Hebrews
were more of a patriarch patriarchal
society than a matriarchal society you
know Jesus shares the parable of the
prodigal son and the Father's love
sometimes he talks about the mother's
love
but you'll often find he talks about the
father's love and the father's sacrifice
and Abraham you know giving his son
showing the greatest faith in love and
friends have you talked to your father
some people I'll be very honest with you
some people struggle in the relationship
with their Heavenly Father because
they've had problems with their earthly
father and you need to realize that your
earthly father will never fail you and
he'll never neglect you and he loves you
more than any earthly connection and we
need to talk to him more to talk to and
address our Father in Heaven we have a
book that we'd like to share with people
that addresses that the book that we'd
like to send you today is called teach
us to pray and it's all about prayer how
do we have a meaningful conversation in
connection with our Heavenly Father I'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
and asks the book is called teach us to
pray the number is 883 five six seven
four seven that is our resource phone
line just asked for the book called
teachers to pray well were happy to send
it to anyone in North America if you're
outside of North America you can take a
look at the granite or the amazing facts
web chat and website and you'll be able
to read that in our free library that's
just amazing fact so RJ we're gonna go
to the phone lines our first caller this
evening we got an eater listening from
Norway
Anita welcome to the program thank you
alright thank you for calling you got to
get real close to your phone we can
barely hear you a little bit and yeah
your question tonight yeah
yeah well I sometimes meet an older man
when I'm out walking and and he talks to
dead people or he thinks he talks to
dead people and my question is really
should I have anything to do with him at
all or should I just try to avoid him
well I don't know if you'll want to have
a lot of close conversation you know if
he's going to be telling you what all
the dead people are telling them because
you might just say you know I don't want
to go there for my religious beliefs but
I we've got a study guide that you can
download I know you're in Norway matter
of fact we've got it it's even
translated in Norwegian but it's are the
dead really did and one of the reasons
that the Bible tells us that we should
not try to consult the dead the Bible
forbids necromancy necromancy is
communicating with the dead or thinking
you can and in Isaiah 8 he said you know
why will the living go to the dead and
the devil's what'd he call it the
spirits of devils work miracles to
deceive that's what happened to King
Saul which his spirit convinced him that
this ghost of samuel was giving him a
message and he died the next day so it's
very dangerous for people to get
involved in
necromancy or the seances of
communicating with the dead now of
course you're referring and nita about
should you even talk to the person well
I think I think we can be friendly to
anyone that we meet we can try and be a
positive example you know we can greet
Jesus's you greet not only your friends
you want to eat greet your strangers you
even want to greet your enemies pray for
the enemies and I think what pastor Doug
says you need to be careful that we
don't get sucked into this but to be a
friendly neighbor to be helpful that's
kind of following the example of Jesus
okay yeah I said I was kind of thinking
that that may be you know not cutting
him off completely but at least not
engage in the you know exactly if he
starts going down the road of talking
about the latest message from the dead
he had I changed the subject
see if you'd be interested in looking at
that study and say do you know what the
Bible says about the dead
and maybe it'll make them stop and think
yeah when the Bible says you think
you're talking to the dead you're
probably talking to demons yeah alright
well thanks for your call Anita we gonna
go to Marty who's listening in New
Jersey Marty welcome to the program
thank you question no man has seen God
what today I ran across exodus 20:4
verse 11 and it seems like trouble
people of hue god yeah alright let me
read this and it's not only here in
Exodus 24 but and pastor also find that
verse in the New Testament where it says
no man has seen the father at any time
yeah Marty in Exodus 24 11 let me read
this for friends I'll start with verse
10 and they saw the God of Israel and
that was there under his feet as it were
a paved work of sapphire stones as it
were the body of heaven in its clearness
and upon the nobles and the children of
Israel he laid his hands so that they
saw God and did eat and drink and so of
course Moses is he's writing here in
Exodus and he's saying you know this is
inconceivable that it had been done
before that people might see something
of the glory of God and just be able to
carry on with their lives and eat and
drink in other words survive now God
remember Moses asked God he said show me
your glory and God said to Moses no man
can see my face and live he even told
Moses you cannot look into the undimmed
face of God's glory or you'll die and so
God said I'll put you in the cleft of
the rock I'll pass by and you'll see me
from behind now in the New Testament the
Bible Jesus makes a statement that no
man has seen the father at any time and
so when people say they've seen God
Jacob wrestled with God Manoah and his
wife the parents of Samson they said
we're gonna die we've seen God and his
wife said well if God wanted to kill us
and he wouldn't have revealed himself to
us
and told us about the baby so they must
have seen what you call a christophany
which is the pre-incarnate glory of
Jesus
you know the verse I think you might be
referring to it's John chapter 1 verse
18 it says no one has seen God at any
time the only begotten Son who is in the
bosom of the Father he has declared him
none are you referring to another verse
pastor Doug where Jesus himself in John
chapter 3 speaks of no one's seeing God
no one has ascended up into heaven but
he that has come down and it's really
talking about bringing a revelation of
who God is so yep there are a few
references that we have there yeah now
though I think I was looking at John 646
not that anyone has seen the Father
except him who is from God he has seen
the father and so when the Bible says no
man has seen God but we think it's
talking more specifically about God the
Father you still there Marty okay
hopefully that helped a little bit they
saw God the Son see well that's a good
this teaches that the Trinity
you got the Father Son and Holy Spirit
so when it says no man has seen God it's
it's talking about seeing the glory of
God the Father because several people
saw different manifestations God says I
spoke to Abraham as a friend and and
Moses and others but of course Bibles is
ultimately we're gonna be in heaven and
we will see his face and I think that's
talking about even the glory of God
Thank You Marty appreciate your question
make fun of their behaviors Diane
listening from Alaska Diane welcome to
the program thank you my question is
very simple and I'll take the answer on
air okay how come there's no whales or
the marine creatures that went on the
Noah's Ark thank you all right Diane
thank you and I think you're calling
from Alaska I'll be up there next month
and anyway you know when the days are
nice and long Sun goes down about
midnight
why are none of the sea creatures
mentioned as being on the ark well of
course they survived in the water
something that's very interesting is the
highest lake in the world is Lake
Titicaca in I think it's Peru and I
could be getting it could be Ecuador
Peru I forget but I think it's Peru and
they've got sharks up there and if the
lake is like 11,000 feet high and you
think well how did it in there
freshwater sharks well in the upheaval
of the world after the flood you know
the the marine creatures survived in the
water during that time yeah you you
almost they pass today it's actually the
the boundary I'm just looking it up now
between Peru and Bolivia is Lake
Titicaca yeah it's a huge lake
yeah it's twelve thousand five hundred
and seven feet high Wow
yeah it up there I think I'd sharks and
the other interesting thing is if you go
to Saudi Arabia they've got a low base
in there it's full of whale bones and
they think that when the oceans receded
a bunch of whales got trapped trapped
there and or they went they really got a
run at it when they got beached
but anyway so you do have marine life
all over the world that survived the
flood they didn't need to be in the ark
and they were in the water alright
thanks for your call Diane we've got
James listening from North Carolina
James welcome to the program thank you
thank you how you doing at the bar baby
you all how you guys doing and your
question is about conversion what is it
I want to be converted how long does it
take to process I'm yeah that's a good
question let me let me just give you a
starter now we can't you know we can't
tell you there's no magic words we're
gonna speak that are gonna bring your
conversion there's a prayer you can pray
with us but the main thing is you make a
decision
you choose with your will to say alright
Lord I believe that you are the son of
God
and that you gave your life for our sins
and I choose to accept your sacrifice in
my place give me the new heart the Bible
says as we look at the goodness of God
the goodness of God and we see that best
on the cross the goodness of God leads
us to repentance we need to love God how
do we love God we love him because he
first loved us as we look at the love of
God and we see the goodness of God it
does something to our hearts and we
invite him to come in and his spirit
moves in and he begins to create in us a
new heart and this is what conversion is
a new heart I will put in you a new
spirit I will put in you and he wants
you to have that experience James that
have you ever prayed and asked God to
have that experience and are you if you
continue to talk to the Lord through
prayer look at him through his word
fellowship with his people as much as
possible these days you behold the
goodness of God it has a transforming
influence on you
you know another way that we can we can
grow in eye experience and I think
conversion or being converted he is yes
it's a moment in time where we ask the
Lord for forgiveness and we have the
assurance we are forgiven and we are
cleansed but we are transformed or
recreated it's not a momentary thing it
really is an experience it's the Spirit
working within us and Jesus likens it to
the growing of a seed and a plant and
and so we ought to grow in I experience
with Jesus we're not to trust solely on
our feelings because sometimes we might
feel uh yes God loves us and I'm you
know rejoicing in the spirit and I have
peace other times we might have trials
certificate doesn't mean God has stopped
loving us but the Bible says we need to
walk by faith not always by sight not
always what we can see or what we can
feel with the other book James we'd be
happy to send you it's called assurance
justification made simple and before we
end our call with you we want to have a
special prayer with you
I'd also like to just mention one of the
ways that we can grow in AI experience
with God is by studying his word and if
you've never done the amazing fact study
guide course it's free it really gets
into the subject of how do we come into
knowing God's will how do we know God's
purpose for our lives what is the Bible
teach us very important course and we've
had testimonies of people pastor that
from around the world who have gone
through this Bible study course and it's
really changed their lives it's made a
great positive impact and so if you
haven't done that James really encourage
you to call and ask for that and sign up
for that but before I give you the phone
number
why don't we pastor like maybe you want
to have a little bit of prayer for James
and then I'll give you the number to
call yes Father in Heaven we're thankful
that we can come before you in
simplicity of faith and just say Lord we
believe that you're real and we believe
that that you love us and that the
father sent you into the world to die in
our behalf for our sins and we accept
that and lord I just pray that you will
give James that experience of a
transformed heart begin to work in him
Lord and help him to cooperate with your
spirit in keeping his eyes fixed on you
that he can live in and walk in the
newness of life and so just bless him
with your presence we pray in Jesus name
Amen amen and James as we mentioned
before the book that we want to send you
is just simply called assurance
justification made simple you can just
ask for the book when you call the
number to call is eight hundred eight
thirty five six seven four seven it's
free eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you might also want to
ask how you can be enrolled in the free
amazing facts Bible study course I
really give you a clear and full
understanding of the various Bible
teachings and I think it'll be an
encouragement to you next caller that we
have we've got CC calling and listening
in Minnesota CC welcome to the program
is that Marty thank you so much thank
you for taking my question
pastor dark possible yes my question is
in book of Revelation chapter four verse
four the 24 elders are they the angels
all those are the redeemed from the
earth
well you know I think there's a third
option as some some believe the 24
elders are a group of people that were
resurrected during the resurrection of
Jesus when he died it says many graves
and this is Matthew 28 many graves were
open and some of the Saints around
Jerusalem were resurrected this may have
been some of the patriarchs and prophets
that lived in the vicinity others
believe you know in the book of Job it
tells us there's a meeting in heaven
where the sons of God come to present
themselves before the Lord and that
these 24 elders are some kind of leading
representatives of the cosmos that God
has made these created leaders of other
worlds or galaxies and and you know
there seems to be some some evidence for
that but it's not the 12 apostles or the
12 judges because you know they haven't
been resurrected yet yeah in job we have
a group of people that the Bible refers
to as the sons of God sort of almost
seeming to be the representatives of
other worlds you know unfallen worlds we
believe our world is the only world that
is sinned and then the devil shows up
sort of representing earth so perhaps
there was this this council and the 24
elders would be those sons of God are
those representatives from those
unfallen worlds we do have a book
talking about this it's called who are
the sons of God and deals with this very
passage I think you'll find that a help
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and you can just ask for the
book called who are the sons of God I
will be happy to send it out to to you
or to anyone that might be listening
next call of the brave is Chris
listening from Florida Chris welcome to
the program thank you for taking my call
[Music]
how can I convince my Jewish friend who
is like 93 years old that the only
Messiah
he doesn't believe that he is not saved
and obviously he denies all the prophecy
connections and things how can I talk to
him you know that is yeah that is a real
challenge because you know I come from a
Jewish background and so many Jews are
raised to believe that you know
Christians have brought so much
suffering on the Jews and that believing
that Jesus is the Messiah is a denial of
their faith and so that they they have a
real struggle with that and I I you know
we did a series a few years ago that is
talked about is it Jewish to be a
Christian and you can is Jesus kosher
for that's right Jesus that's that I I
went kind of spaced on that yeah is
Jesus kosher for the Jews and it's
myself and two other Jew Jewish
Christians that are talking about that
you might share that DVD with him and
you can find that at the amazing facts
website that's the only thing I can
think of now is something he may not
read a book that you gave but maybe you
watch the DVD and who knows what the
Lord will do in his heart thanks for
your call Chris I think we have time for
one more caller before I break we got
Cape listening from New York Kate
welcome to the program and they claim to
grant you any wish you if you touch
their belly or kisses their legs yeah
and soon have a baby so my question is
is they were powerful enough to give a
child to human all right so now it is
possible that the devil can for example
make a person sick and then when they
pray to him or they flip a coin or wish
on a star didn't get better I mean he
can remove it he can give it to him and
he can remove
it sometimes the Lord in his mercy
answers the prayers of the pagans
because they don't know you know God
says he sends the sunshine Jesus said
God sends the sunshine in the rain on
the just and the unjust and so there
might be a pagan couple and they've just
been praying for a baby and so they go
to the temple and they may you know make
an offering to buddha or whatever it is
and you know God may still answer there
/ cuz he's a loving God and they don't
know any better
but yeah the devil doesn't have prayer
to give a lie he doesn't have a power to
give life or to resurrect you know only
God can create life the devil does have
the power to sometimes you know help a
person win at the blackjack table or
something like that and when they're
there wishing for luck and I'm sure that
he's got some influence and power in
that area anyway Kate I hope that helps
a little bit you know we do have a
lesson did God create the devil tells
you about some of the limits and some of
the abilities of the devil not that we
should spend a lot of time on that but
we do have scriptures about it and we'll
be happy to share that with you the
number to Coley's 883 five six seven
four seven you just asked for the study
guide cult did God create the devil
don't go far friends we're just taking a
breath taking a break coming back and
more Bible questions on the way in just
a moment
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com you're
listening to Bible answers live where
every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 hi good morning
good morning morning there but how are
you different and your question was 19
it says no more three songs they fill
the whole earth so did they move to as
they some claim three different
continents Asia Africa Europe or how do
we well when it talks about Noah's sons
it means that Noah had no other children
after his three sons and it only talks
about eight individuals on the ark
I think Peter mentions that and so the
whole world was repopulated through
Noah's sons it doesn't say that they
divided up after the ark and went to
three different continents because after
they left the ark the descendants of
Noah they were marrying with each other
I'm sure that they were you know
marrying across family lines brothers
married sisters back then and cousins
married cousins
probably several generations went by
before they were divided from the Tower
of Babel so it was not just the three
sons of Noah going in three different
directions so you know a lot of the the
descendants of where the reason you have
Semites you know in Bible talks about
being anti-semitic the Semites are the
descendants of
Shem and then you've got the descendants
of ham you get the descendants of
Japheth but there's a little bit of
cross pollinating that went on before
they divided from the Tower of Babel
okay
thank you thank you very much appreciate
your question next one of the B heavies
Aaron listening right here in Carmichael
California Aaron welcome to the program
hi I had a question it was about heaven
once we're obviously have glorified
bodies and we are in heaven and secured
our salvation secured will we go on to
explore the world like I what's our
what's our jobs gonna be like and also
don't you think people are going to
continue to procreate even after we're
in heaven
all right the person yeah you got a
couple questions in there let's start
with first what will we be doing you
know the Bible tells us and I think it's
in Isaiah 11 pastor Ross it says they'll
plant vineyards and eat the fruit of
them we will build houses and inhabit
them and Mytyl like what long enjoy the
fruit of their hands and so we're going
to be doing productive active
constructive things you know God made
this world and he told man to go forth
and subdue it to you know to build and
develop and and but I don't think we're
going to be restricted to this world I
think that we're going to go beyond that
there'll be dreams and visions and
inventions and and exploration you know
God is a creator he wants us to create
and God gives his people different gifts
some people are gonna love gardening and
horticulture others might want building
some are gonna like to maybe travel and
do and be ambassadors for God I
personally can't wait to go exploring
through the cosmos now you know there
are verses that say things like they
will mount up with wings like eagles so
it implies we can fly there so you got
that song Rock of Ages it says will soar
to Worlds unknown that's not the Bible
that's in him but I think it's based on
good theology that we're not going to be
confined to any one world you asked
about having children and procreating
the world is going to be inhabited with
the redeemed I don't know you know Jesus
makes it pretty clear they'll be no
new marriage in heaven and so I can't
remember the scripture offhand but don't
think we're gonna be procreating in the
new earth that the world will be
populated with the redeemed and if they
did continue to procreate it would only
be you know just after 10,000 years the
planet would be spilling over with
people so now pastor you mention that
verse in Isaiah 65 verse 21 it's
actually yeah verse 21 it says they
shall build houses and inhabit them they
shall plant vineyards and eat the fruit
of them they will not build on another
inhabit they shall not plant another eat
so that's right it's kind of describing
what life is gonna be like in the new
earth that God creates thanks for your
call Aryan we do have a study guide
talking about him and it's called
colossal city in space and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks then I'm gonna call if you'd
like to receive that study guide he's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again you can answer that
study guide called colossal city in
space I'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks next caller
that we have is from Brazil we have mud
one listening
Madonn welcome to the program I've got
marty is that Marty I think it's mud one
in some Paulo Brazil we've got two
different numbers on a different evening
you know tell us your name Maru Marwan
Marwan okay welcome and your question
this evening thank you my question is I
read some time ago in the Book of
Ezekiel in mentions a lot of verses
regarding some process about a
construction of a new temple and I was
wondering about this new temple because
it's there are denominations that
believe that the third temple would be
built in the future for instance and I
was wondering about the meaning of this
temple that there are a lot of verses in
this video yeah you can read from
Ezekiel 40
seven it you've got it and yeah and I
think even a zekiel 46 yeah I talked
about the outer Court so yes you're
wondering is this a literal temple that
is going to be built yes I'm not sure
I'm not clear in my mind because there
are many how can I say different beliefs
about that I guess yeah all right well
that is a good question I think that
this is something of what shall I say
it's it's like a dual prophecy for one
thing he talks about water flowing from
the throne of God and everywhere the
water goes everything lives now Jesus
talks about the water of life and he
said he is the water of life in
Revelation it does talk about a river
flows from the throne of God and it's a
living water and so I think Ezekiel is
seen a couple of things here one he's
seen that you know our limps --is of the
City of God and the redeemed but I think
more than that he's seen a vision of the
church there are three apocalyptic
prophets maybe for a prop what they call
apocalyptic prophets in the Bible one is
revelation
Daniel Zechariah and Ezekiel they had
visions in symbolic language and some of
their visions are so full of symbols
that you need to look for symbolic
fulfillment you know Jesus said destroy
this temple that is made with hands and
in three days I will make one without
hands he spoke of his body the body of
Christ is the temple of God and Ezekiel
was talking about this this temple I
think it's a spiritual temple as well
talking about the church that was going
to fill the earth because in Ezekiel's
time they'd been conquered by the
Babylonians and the Persians and they
wondered if God's people would ever you
know come back again now the temple that
was built by a Nehemiah and Ezra was
nothing like the one that Ezekiel
describes what does he feel describes is
much bigger so I think you have to apply
that spiritually mm-hmm we do have a
study guide that talks about the temple
and what it represents the different
ceremonies sacrifice isn't alike and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and ask now of course you're
in Brazil so you might want to take a
look at the study guide online at the
amazing facts website but it's called
God drew the plans and it's all about
the temple and the significance and the
sanctuary and the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and you can ask for that
study guide called God drew the plants
next call at the behalf we gonna listen
to or get a hold of sand relief in
Missouri Sandra welcome to the program
oh thank you for taking my call yeah I
have a question it's Jesus the Archangel
Michael right now before I answer that
question let me clarify what is meant by
that is Jesus and angel know the
Archangel means the highest messenger
and so you've got Michael the Archangel
in the Bible and the word Michael means
who is as God
now Michael the Archangel is not an
angel like a cherubim or a Seraphim
Michael the Archangel is more of a title
in the Old Testament that and you've
mentioned it's mentioned a couple times
in the New Testament and many believe
that it's describing Christ in his
pre-incarnate of position he is the son
of God but they used the term sometimes
Michael the Archangel now let's look at
some of the evidence if you read in 1st
Thessalonians chapter 4 it says the Lord
Himself will descend from heaven with
the voice of the Archangel the Lord with
the voice of the Archangel Oh
that's Jesus you read in the book of
Jude verse 9 Michael comes he does not
argue with the devil over the body of of
Moses but says the Lord rebuke thee here
Michael saying the same thing to the
devil that jesus said to the devil when
he was tempted in the wilderness when he
said get thee behind me Satan or the
Lord rebukes you and Michael resurrects
Moses Jesus is the resurrection of the
life you read in Daniel chapter 12 that
at that time Michael will stand up and
there'll be a great time of trouble such
as there never has been
Michael the Great Prince that stands for
the children of thy people who is the
Great Prince that is our intercessor
well that's Christ and then you can read
where Joshua takes his shoes off his
feet as he bowels before this angel of
the Lord well we're not supposed to
worship anyone but God and yet this
angel said take your shoes off and he
worshiped before him so we believe that
Michael is a pre-incarnate name for
Jesus and this is you know this was a
belief of many of the Protestant
reformers we have a book on that we do
the book is called who is Michael the
Archangel and just to add to that pass
the back the the word the ark angel
means ruler of the Angels just like an
ark is above something
so we have the ark angel is the ruler of
the angels not saying that Jesus is an
angel all things that were made were
made by him or through him but he is the
great messenger that brings God's will
to man and great to study if you'd read
the book it's called who is Michael the
Archangel that I'm going to call is 808
three five six seven four seven and
again just asked for the book called who
is Michael the Archangel a next caller
to behave is Anthony listening in New
York Anthony welcome to the program
hello good evening pastor Dagon pastor
Ross evening um so I know that we don't
believe in astrology or anything like
that but we also know that seeing has a
counter set for everything God has
created or that God has so I was
wondering is there something biblical a
biblical side to astrology that Satan
has counterfeited my book you know I was
probably do today where you know were
people who are born in a certain time of
the year houses you know generally have
certain types of traits and Christian
you know things like that all right well
I remember a few years ago hearing
evangelist D James Kennedy he preached a
sermon and he said the ancient origins
of astrology were really telling a story
of the gospel with the you know they
went through the different symbols the
bull and and the fish and different
things and he went through the twelve
and
made in their comparison it sounded a
little sound a little sketchy to me now
there's nothing wrong with astronomy
astronomy is of course legitimate
science of studying the heavens and
astrology the idea now they use it
originally for time and seasons nothing
wrong if you've got a calendar but when
you start saying a person born under
these months and this time of year is
predestined to have certain
characteristics and they're gonna get
along with this person because they're
in a Aquarius and other persons of
Pisces and no I think that's the stuff
the Bible forbids
everyone's destiny is is open to you
know God's providence it's not being
governed by stars that are billions of
light-years away that have no
illumination or gravitational impact on
the earth there's just you know there's
no connection so yeah I'm we do have
actually a lesson that talks about that
yeah it's called simply does God inspire
astrologists and psychics and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and ask the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven after the study guide called does
God inspire psychics or serologist
thanks for your call our next caller is
let's see Dianne is listening from New
Zealand Dianne welcome to the program
great thank you I would like to say
thank you right messages and yes I would
like to thank you thanks so much for
calling no question because you're
studying Daniel um in the last two years
it's quite a long period so the question
here is because we're up to Daniel
chapter 10
so Daniel chapter 10 between Daniel's
reaction to his vision from God very
different to the previous visions that
he got in Daniel chapter seven eight and
nine
I'm it's very rare in Scripture that we
hear about you know the prophets
physical reactions and they actually
receive a vision um the liberal
nevertheless so in case of Daniel we
were informed that he had no strength in
him which was mentioned in Daniel
chapter 10 verse 8 that he had no
strength left
it was helpless and he fell on his face
and so technically we can see as though
Daniel is dead because that could also
show like as a metaphorically I guess
because even in John who was right in
the book of Revelation on the island of
Patmos the earth fell at his feet as
though dead uh-huh would you just caught
it yeah we gotta hurry up and make this
into a question and we're gonna run out
of time God's glory in Daniel Chapter
King you say that was it when he saw
God's glory in Daniel chapter chapter 9
or 10 that you read about his response
his reaction wave falls to the ground as
a dead one or no breath left in him then
without a doubt there is a special
revelation of God's glory that Daniel
sees in this chapter in Revelation
chapter 10 it's also interesting to note
that when a prophet sees the glory of
God he feels his unworthiness I think of
Isaiah who envisioned saw God high and
lifted up upon a throne and he said woe
is me so it is a humbling experience
without a doubt and when you see the
glory of God it was overwhelming and he
fell as they was there there was no
strength left in him but God
strengthened him and lifted him up we
find a very similar experience with John
there's one of the disciples that God
strengthened him as well so I think
that's just a revelation of God's glory
yeah if you read in John chapter
revelation sorry chapter 1 when John
sees Jesus and vision it says when I saw
him I fell at his feet as dead but he
laid his right hand on me and said don't
be afraid so
several of the the prophets Isaiah
Daniel Ezekiel John when they saw God in
vision they were often overcome and they
seemed to have no breath and and
probably looked to those around as
though they were dead kind of like Paul
when he saw the Lord on the road to
Damascus the people who are with him
were befuddled by his what was happening
to him all right well thanks for your
thanks good to get called I am Norway
and all over the world to Abu Dhabi
International a program tonight let's
see we have Ernest from New Jersey
Ernest welcome to the program thank you
you're gonna want to turn your radio
down Ernest because we're hearing
ourselves and we we don't want to hear
any more voices in our head right now
yeah I have a question and the question
relates to Genesis 49 verses 8 to 12
okay man this was dead before Jacob knew
died no he summoned all his children yes
and when he got to Judah the blessings
that no he proclaimed on Judah you know
was he really prophesying the coming of
our Lord and Savior and unbeknownst to
him it sound like no the blessings I
pronounce on Judah was probably a
prophecy on the coming of Jesus we
believe it was in verse 10 when Jacob is
giving the blessing or the benediction
to Judah now first of all the longest
blessing he gives his to Joseph Joseph
was his his favorite son and through
Joseph the bigger tribes of Ephraim came
but through Judah he says the scepter
will not depart from Judah nor a
lawgiver from between his feet until
Shiloh comes and many have believed it
you know this is a messianic prophecy
talking about Jesus coming and it says
they'll come forth a rod from the stem
of Jesse David came and Jesus is a
descendant of David as it's prophesied
from Judah and the genealogy of Judah is
given in the book of Matthew so yeah we
think and Judah is the one let's just
keep this in mind when Joseph was going
to be alright when Joseph was going to
keep a Benjamin Judah's one who said I
am offering my
offices substitute so Judah became the
the mediator and the intercessor not
Reuben not the firstborn not even Levi
it was Judah the fourth son of alia that
was one who offered himself alright
thanks for your cold earnest
we've got Esther listening from
Mississippi Esther
thanks for your patience and your
question about the church it is
structured it would seem to suggest that
rationally decisions are a distraction
and the church should focus on seeking
the love of Christ and revealing it to
others but this is the church review the
love of Christ by speaking up against
these justices I mean if a group is
saying that there is suffering for
centuries to the one of the priorities
of the church need to actively help
alleviate the suffering
I mean Esther do you believe I mean let
me just jump in do you believe that
racial injustice is the result of
education or it's the result of sin so
the most important thing we can do to
help resolve racial injustice is helping
people have hearts that love their
brother if people are pretending to love
their brother because of education are
just because of you know political
pressure that's not the solution the
solution is to really love their
brothers and this is why the gospel is
the best solution I think now I jumped
in I shouldn't have done it because I
think she dressed the question to you
pastor Ross sorry well I good question
yes and of course this is probably
appropriate time for people to be
talking about this when it seems that
there is a lot of discussion going on I
think as Christians in our interaction
without this there is no excuse
whatsoever for us to show any degree of
unkindness or racism the Bible is very
clear that we all the children of God he
has made all of us of one blood and your
ID there is a balance Christian's we
want to present the guy
which is the true antidote that can
bring unity and peace at the same time I
think in our own lies and an interaction
with people we want to present truth we
want to speak up for truth and those who
are being oppressed but the most
important thing that I think we as
Christians can do is to present the
gospel of Jesus Christ that transforms
the life and I think we want to be the
salt of the earth we want to be the best
example we can be I really want to
follow Christ's example in all things
and I think if ever we in doubt look at
what Jesus did what did he emphasized in
his ministry
it was ministering to the poor it was
preaching the gospel
it was demonstrating the love of God in
all that he did he worked to save Romans
who were oppressing the Jews and the
Greeks right along with reaching out to
the the Jews in other words Jesus showed
what Peter says God is no respecter of
persons you know even amongst the
disciples of Jesus they took a period of
time where they'd overcome their
cultural biases there's many examples of
where they questioned why Jesus would
speak to the woman at the well or some
of the things he said to the non-jews
they had just been so entrenched in
their way but Jesus made it very clear
in his example in his ministry that we
ought to manage to do all people and
Christ died for everyone so thank you
Esther thanks for your patience and
holding on for that that was appreciate
your patience we've got angel that's
calling from Oregon angel we've got just
about two minutes and your question I
even window when they don't go to church
or well there will be people who will be
saved that did not go to church to get
baptized is usually extenuating
circumstances a person under normal
conditions when they learn about Jesus
they want to follow him and Jesus says
go and be baptized I mean it's a very
clear teaching of Jesus one of the last
things he says when he sends to heaven
go teach and baptize you know have
people commit their lives to me and the
other thing is we're baptized into the
body of Christ
so if a person says if a young man says
to a girl I love you and I want to marry
you but I don't want to live with you
she immediately would say something's
wrong with that if we say we love the
Lord and we want to commit our lives to
him we would want to be married and we
would want to live with him
so baptism is like the marriage ceremony
and joining the church is being part of
his family so why are you asking this
I'm curious and actually had this
question for a long time she must have
had a question and I tried to talk to
him about it
so he wanted here you know a pastor and
he also alone we got a saying for what
if the people that are close to death
when and they accept Jesus Christ as the
Saviour they're saying then quiet down
how are they saved you know well you
know you know baptism if a person can't
be saved like I mean if it can't be
baptized like the thief on the cross in
just the last you know hours of his life
he turned to Jesus Jesus saved him he
said you're gonna be in paradise he
didn't have time to get baptized or go
to church but he swore all saved by
grace we're not saved by our works
whatever they might be that man probably
never had a communion service either but
he'll be in heaven so ultimately we're
saved by our faith in Christ but then
once we're saved we want to follow where
Jesus leads if friends we don't have
time for another question but we want to
tell everybody thank you for calling and
I see Brenda and Valerie and Leah and
Angel and Debby if we didn't get to your
calls I think we didn't get to angel
call us again next week we're gonna be
here God willing they'll study is word
together and if you are blessed by the
program's please visit the amazing facts
website help us stay on this station you
can just click donate we would sure
appreciate it
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vo RG DT no amazing backs has
a free Bible school that you can do from
the comfort of your own home it includes
27 beautifully illustrated study lessons
to aid in your study of God's Word sign
up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 for 257,000 that's
one eight forty four two one five seven
thousand
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at www.att.com/biz
[Music]
Iorek DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at
you
[Music]